I'm we do in another dual commentary
game and let's go so make sure to to
watch both videos going for simple
Queens pong game which now transposes to
the Slav exchange variation pretty
content with that because I know
kingscrusher likes to attack the king
and get active play this is not the most
ideal opening for that so let's see
which line it will go for with no idea
if he knows a bit about this yeah a 6
it's a very popular line ideas to wait
for e3 and then in with this reform
that's why I go rook c12 to wait a bit
can order h3 to prevent the bishop from
going to g4 yeah now the question Bishop
d3 yard there should be two I got for
Bishop e2 I'm not sure about Bishop d3
Bishop f5 this could be could be an idea
the black
actually it's a bit surprising that he
decided to play G cigs and the castle
the bishop because it's not doing very
much because of the d4 III information
yeah this was to be expected My dear was
so queen bee three now actually just
have a quick look if this is really
working night a five I would just play
Queen a four I think ideas to simply
attack d5 and b7 okay he decides to take
now now I can take with the rook and get
really some annoying pressure because he
cannot play rook to be eight because of
the bishop on f4 and yeah he can play
moves like this but it already looks a
bit weird so now my between be4 not sure
what he what he's doing now because you
should see seven is simply the threat he
retreats to c6 I could take b7 looks
like you have to go for really ugly move
now moves that you didn't want it to
play in the first place maybe not c4
even and then it's an incision if I
would take pawn on c4 yeah it actually
happened um yeah I can take a pawn on c4
now on b7
take on c4 DC rook takes the especially
three if I tag with the Queen he has no
immediate way of from getting the poem
back rook c8 maybe it's still just an
extra porn yeah I think play it simple
and I shouldn't spend so much time yeah
yeah of course it's got the bishop am
and this is some bit of compensation
maybe just Quincy 72 to get more pieces
exchanged or get the Queen back to the
eighth not sure if he wants to go to the
aid really maybe it's not so bad to to
go there but it doesn't look very active
okay it takes on f3 now I could actually
take on d8 first and then play this pawn
up and get me up this looks very nice
yeah okay but this is a little bit bit
of desperation already I take with the
bishop you might exchange Beirut dt2 but
I have root b 3 so this is a convenient
way to to cover the queenside p.m.
now the only idea would be rooted CA to
see two to get something here but I have
Roxy one first also roop c6 now yeah he
could she could actually try to play
rook e 2 and then rock d to maybe just
king of 12 to get this out of the
position
yeah it's two points the other doubled
but they also have a lot of square so
yeah maybe thats it's a quite decent
idea really to get them to get more
activity I could play rook c6 though the
idea of Luke f6 also to cover f4 from
here maybe this one I don't want to take
and allow rookie five okay yeah just
stroke of 6 to cover everything now take
with the pawn and I also activates the
rook on the third-ranked now I don't
think he we took that into account g3
check now he six this is just
threatening or graph seven with mate
Brooke f 78 and meet so now I could
could actually take with the porn also
and rook the eight maybe maybe that
maybe I played that a tad too quickly
OOP the aid this could be
hmm this a bit annoying
yeah not much of a choice but this was
wasn't good play by me really ok let's
play it simple I don't have much time so
I want to go for the complete loops or
doesn't give me that
Wow my comp is really slowing me down
here no idea why even and even see have
even slower than usual i hope i can i
can manage somehow but it looks
difficult i go off a drawn our idea of
he's taking it yeah it's it's it's
awfully slow here no idea even slower
than usual okay let's go for the second
game this will be another video us to
stop now and then start a new one